[Music]
and no days off news oh no y-you mean
days off me balance now dude you got
work hustle work work house possible
that's true I hate those people work
25/8 submitted by your boy from
Cincinnati yeah boy Oh sometimes I
forget they exist that's true
Cincinnatians yeah is that Ohio I don't
even know I think so I hope so cool
since I got the state right I feel sorry
for you guys it's one of those cities
isn't that why Trump won cuz we forget
about middle America Ron oh sure
our school district is replacing snow
days off with online classes where I
read that like [ __ ] it's [ __ ] a school
district or a blazing snow days off with
online class that was the only thing
they could look forward to in a shitty
situation and you know we never had snow
days off they're leveling the plane yeah
we never had I did yeah three though
we're in Dallas Oh where'd you grow up
again I was in the East Coast in
Virginia dude we had snow days it was
tight we had snow ed classes all the
time we're supposed to we never had
those cool days off I tornado days or
hurricane days we had all those days it
was just drill but everyone has bond
days are bonded everyone is five days
molester days bond days like you guys
don't get that like that freaking shady
like drawing that the police did I'll
put in front of your school hey don't
come to school tomorrow this guy's been
lurking around I did did you have a lot
of pedophiles in your neighborhood her
stuff I saw police sketches posted
around but then the bomb threat days we
actually had a bomb threat we had to
stay in the classroom for the whole day
and that was fun you didn't get the day
off
it was the same classroom so we got to
hang out for the rest I like oh there's
a bomb threat but then they kicked you
next to the bomb yeah I don't know
there's a bomb threat kids getting to
keep staying
everyone hold a cup of gasoline just
keep passing around dude but that's like
diehard 3 where they've none of the kids
could beat the school so maybe that's
part of the bomb threat Oh cousin tired
three offending kids left the school
he's gonna blow through how do you
always do this because I have a kid I
gotta watch it in bits and pieces i
watch the kid I know what he's talking
about what do you mean I watch in the
morning from 5 to 7 that's me
what am I in the morning for 30 minutes
I can't wait till he's old enough to
schedule a meeting with you because he
needs to talk next week I told you next
Monday ok we don't look what it says
Amal what read it easy
we don't do walk-ins if you look that's
right no walk-ins not even your mother
gets walking why do you why would you
but I just found out that was Hans
Gruber's brother it's connected
that shit's so old I don't even know
what y'all talk you're like good
swaddler dude that's like a 90s movie I
know my dad but by Darb 3 the best tired
of my opinion it's pretty good so far a
school district in South Carolina is
getting rid of their snow days and
replacing it with E classrooms I've ever
in Cincinnati how convincing some no no
Cincinnati yeah as our fan I just kind
of jumped on Cincinnati yeah yeah so
this drawing South Carolina and so
they're saying that this program will
let students access assignments via a
Google classroom with chromebook devices
that they'll be taking home I'm getting
anxiety thinking about it I'm sad you
know what I didn't know though something
I've discovered while reading this
article here that I never knew exciting
grew up where there's snow they actually
have makeup days in June and so kids go
to back to school at the end of June
that's [ __ ] whole I never had that
but then they're saying that in this
school district so by having these
classrooms they'll be saving a lot of
money because then they won't be having
school buses trying to transport all
these kids because they only get a
quarter of the classroom body actually
show up before those makeup days I think
school trains people to be half
asked and try to do the least amount of
work for the most amount of pay because
even till this day at my old ass-fucking
age when I hear homework I start hurt
like hurting my soul starts cracking
apart and in my heart is beating fast
like all I have a sign man I gotta do
and then like I just have I just think
about homework and I'm like [ __ ] me man
I don't want to do it it makes me feel
like up Graves disease or some [ __ ] you
get anxious just want to pass out
homeworks giving me Graves disease with
Isaac like I'm just like I'm just as
fast as I can to try to spend time away
from whatever I wanted they didn't care
if it was right they just cared if you
did I just did [ __ ] hieroglyphics in
my math and you still get a seat yeah
that's right it was awesome what do you
do what are you doing that's like stuff
you don't remember you don't know yeah
oh we're not there yeah I'll let you
know in like two years
[ __ ] no that luckily though he's an
after-school program now and all the
homework it's been a lifesaver in our
house cuz man we would spend like hours
and hours trying to help I feel so sad
for anyone that has to do homework I
would pull all children out of school
you don't have a kid one day right [ __ ]
that okay no school oh don't don't you
have to send your kid to school I'm
taking going to [ __ ] smoothie me home
school you're gonna tell no crazy I'm
gonna have Socrates come back to life
they got homework at home school I know
they just have work yes that is dirty at
home you got room work just work you see
that's different though when I think of
home school my heart starts to open up
like oh this is interesting
I could figure out the curriculum from 6
a.m. to 7 knife skills from 7 to you
like that guy that 6 a.m. sorry no that
one dude that we talked about when he
raises his kid and homeschooling babies
is all about
he made a whole bunch a seven to eight
American history eight to nine breakfast
or world culinary arts nine to ten
naptime ten to twelve lunch oh you have
breakfast then you think a nap and then
your that and then you start today with
recess weapons our knife skills yeah and
then after lunch then it's specialized
time so like like will have an interest
of the year so you dedicate that whole
year to that interest and if it's like
baking then I'm gonna make you a master
[ __ ] baker by the end of the year
they have to make the best cupcakes ever
my school is I want to get the most
Awkward men in the world and have them
teach young boys how to pick up women oh
gee guys you just you just like super
leg high [ __ ] and you're like hey here's
the teacher he's really knows his [ __ ]
and I just want to see what the [ __ ]
that's so sad it would make me crazy
well no I don't know not to my kids but
I just want to see what that would be
like what do you what do you would say
oh my like hey man we're gonna pay you
to teach this class and you have to
really teach these kids how to pick up
women and you're gonna take a job
seriously
oh yeah well he wants to make the money
and he wants to keep it going cuz that's
how people are they have a survival
mentality so like I'll figure it out and
then I want to see this guy like show it
would be the most fascinating thing I
can think of that's a reality show
waiting that there was a reality show
where they got a bunch of guys and then
they had to go out and like pick up
girls and stuff like that oh yeah there
was a bunch of that and then there was
this one those guys are good
no they were they were just straight-up
nerds like they didn't know what they
were doing but there was one kid that I
[ __ ] absolutely loved because he got
so desperate he was like [ __ ] I just
need a girl right so he started asking
grandmas and everybody just so he could
win the game hell that's pretty smile
really he was like can someone just give
me their number
yeah dad going broke the [ __ ] class
hell man
so wait so who was teaching the class
though it was a peacocking guy right
like it was one of those uh the guys who
become you're talking about keys come on
dude
no you peacock all the time as you do it
are you talking about what if I see him
doing the kitties pong game on Tiffa see
all the time what are you calling a show
when you like show you show you like you
gotta flex a little bit you're [ __ ]
me I'm a peacock a lot all the time you
do to me picking up this no we don't
want you wearing those flowery jackets
and [ __ ] like pimp coats and stuff and
like [ __ ] works so apparently I'm not
putting that pickup artists guys oh
that's true it depends it's a [ __ ]
tracks yeah having a nice car like this
peacock
right exactly
true true so that's I'm saying we get
those guys to teach mmm that we've
already seen mm-hmm I want to see the
guys who pee their pants when they see
women teach a class to kids about how to
pick up women the teens it's fine look
because all the peacocking shows man
there's so I I find them so like you
know it's so [ __ ] broke ultry like
it's like dude like all these chicks
like secretly fantasize about being
raped dude so you're like you just won I
mean like these guys are like really
like it's like trust me like the female
anatomy like they're built to be
penetrated so they're waiting for
somebody to who penetrates them mentally
so that you can get to the physically
and like all those guys you know yeah so
I wanna I wanna I don't know that those
guys are the worst and so I think it'd
be interesting to see the opposite
spectrum the Steve Urkel's absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]